yesterday I had a one-on-one with the
NBA's reigning Most Valuable Player
Stephon Curry of the Golden State
Warriors I began by asking him how TV
deals and endorsements have affected the
heart of the game this is the business
of being stuff there's more
extracurriculars going on around the
game itself but the spirit of it and and
what we do is as the players that never
changes we go out to play to win and it
doesn't matter you know how many people
are watching or where the TV money is
going or what they that part of the game
will never change how do you see the
business changing in the next five years
basketball I think it's just going
global and you know whether it's in Asia
whether it's in India whether it's in
Europe you find more and more people
following the league and being a part
attached to it so I know I'm still doing
a great job of catering a lot of things
we do here in the states to make it more
appealing to the to the worldwide
audience and they're becoming no more
greater basketball fans all around the
world are you the underdog many people
look at you as an undervalued asset you
kind of always have been not getting the
look to go to Wake Forest going to
Davidson Golden State Warriors where
you're a star but you're the fifth
highest paid player on the team does
that frustrate you what does that mean
no I don't frustrate me I'm a great
opportunity to play this game and I'm
able to take care of my family and do
what I need to do I think everything
will turn around when you were a kid
obviously your dad a basketball star but
when you first started playing were you
the best one on your team never never
not even through high school I was
always the shortest kid skinniest kid
that always had to just work for
everything so how did that change how's
it did he just click probably my senior
year I kind of broke through the
threshold of being the guy that people
come and came to watch play but it was
just a moment like all that work that
you put into it it just it just it
definitely just clicked when I think
about Knicks games or Laker games and
la courtside you've got all the movie
stars in New York you've got all the New
York celebrities San Francisco is known
for tech stars are they filling the
arena you got Mark Zuckerberg cheering
you on the person you got and Twitter
guys the Facebook guys they're showing
up so both may be mine I know their face
they know their name for sure they know
that what they're about but more and
more you see them getting highlighted
coming to our games and becoming those
marquee celebrities that come out to our
games and then support from a business
perspective does it make sense for an
arena to be in Oakland or closer to San
Francisco where the money is at I think
there's two ways to think about it I
think the biggest thing is just having a
state-of-the-art arena you can put it
anywhere in the bay San Francisco is
where they're planning on putting it
which probably will be a successful move
but having a state-of-the-art arena
which they're planning on building is
going to be special for the entire Bay
Area come next year when there's new TV
deals is that the right time to try to
push and renegotiate even though your
deals not off we'll see you know the
time is it's all about time in the NBA
and how you know each year is pretty
much different so in two years I'm up
we'll see what happens down the road
it's hard to really predict because
every you know everything so fluid in
the NBA but I've always said I want to
stay in the bay just because I love it I
love living there I love playing there
and hopefully that happens
do you like the year to year contract
idea like LeBron House which gives you
more flexibility or in order to be a
team leader do you like to know where
you're going to be for a long period of
time I think you really have to assess
the situation as you go through like
LeBron is doing that for a reason
because it wants that flexibility to be
able to obviously get what he would he
would he's would he wear these are Odin
market value and all that but having
that security is also great for some
players do you want to bring other guys
women onto the roster and make a bigger
team a bigger Under Armor team not just
a Morrison
I never said definitely a
partner and obviously with the
partnership we announced last year you
know that being this thing for hopefully
for life is especially the next ten
years like being able to grow the brand
whether it's basketball with the
basketball business or across all the
different different sports
have you called Cam Newton this week you
giving him some advice how do you prep
for a championship I've taken the
approach of letting him be I haven't
gone through a championship series
myself you know six months ago
you're so locked in and focused one
thing I did tell what tell him is
there's nothing special you have to do
be the same can be the same Panthers
team that's gotten you to the Super Bowl
but enjoy the moment when you are
getting ready for your championship week
would you eat would you watch would you
listen to how did you prep for that
ultimate game I try to keep everything
the same like it you don't want to psych
yourself out I had the same routine the
same pregame meals listen we all know I
follow her on Instagram your wife she
make you something specific before each
game it's any we have it's just
different types but all sorts of pregame
pastas we call them there's so mix and
match up so I take like a two-hour nap
on game day and when I wake up you get
this fresh smell of something she's
whipping up and it's a seriously pretty
good so you're not visualizing the game
you're clearing your mind I actually go
out to the court and try to just think
about three to five minutes and just
stare at the court and visualize what
I'll be doing on there and the game plan
they're kind of seeing things happen
before I actually step foot on the floor
how about the message of a family brand
this is not Charles Barkley's basketball
anymore where he said I don't need to be
an icon I don't need to be an idol you
become one I embrace it but it's just
basically me being me this is a I'm not
very you know pretty public with with my
life and the things that are important
to me my family is included in that and
what's the best advice you've ever
gotten
I'm guessing it's from your father
yeah he basically wanted to tell me
the true sign of a man's character is
how they treat somebody that can't do
anything for them what's your guilty
pleasure you've got to have a flaw here
I'm going to big the biggest sweet tooth
in the history of the world so if I see
a bowl of candy or something I'm going
after it
I'm going after it if there wasn't
basketball what would there be for you
Dwyane Wade said he'd be a singer I
would try to be with my man jordan
Spieth and be on the PGA Tour that's
like my my second love
I would love to pursue that had
basketball not been in my
in my life so but Tom Brady loves
basketball so you Brady Spieth who would
be in your foursome me
Brady Spieth and seem Under Armour right
there who would be or fourth I'm gonna
go with President Obama yeah I played
with him before I'm bringing him back
for a rematch you better golfer than
he's yeah he played golf with President
Obama listen I wonder which one of them
was more excited I wonder if I wonder
who is Steph Curry or President Obama I
would expect Steph Curry would be better
at the / than the President of the
United States I think Steph probably has
more time to play I don't wait you say
you think he's better at golf the
President Obama is he's got a 1 handicap
he told us Wow